uh I appreciate your perspective on uh
the dichotomy between men and women in
relationships and I have to ask you uh
I'm going to present a scenario to you
okay and I want your take on it yeah
okay let's say
you're 50 years old s yes you get
divorced
yes within uh oh let's say you meet a
young lady who's 31 mhm right you're 50
she's
31 four to five weeks later you're with
this young lady and you have decided to
get her name tattooed on your body four
to five
times wow that's that's that's insane
okay yeah that's insane because you're a
free man finally you're a free man but
what most men do they look for the most
difficult thing to do in their life they
instead of taking an easy route most men
will go down a path of difficulty and
set themselves up for pain again and
some people maybe unnecessary stress
unnecessary stress because if you're
50 and you got a girl that's 30 she
still hasn't lived yet so all you can do
is you know you di her down you take her
shopping she feels good and cuz she's
still a child right 31 she hasn't lived
so in today's world that's called a simp
in a sense because these girls don't
they don't respect a man like that at my
that's if it was a 60 something year old
woman or like even a 45y old or even 45
a 31 with the way the world is today
just to have that they on the phone
talking about the man who they're pretty
used pretty much using like oh yeah he
brought me this he brought me that you
know because a woman who's like actually
understands the way the world Works
already would look at somebody who would
get four tattoos on their body in four
weeks of their name and be a little
absolutely so he's something wrong with
him he's crazy he's a
psycho yeah that's my man I know you're
talking about and and and and and the
thing and the thing that I wanted to
make sure even though I know he's here
here ladies and gentlemen I didn't I
didn't want
to change who I was with my answers no
this is the answer yeah because right
cuz I could have easily lied and been
something else cuz I know he's here he
need to hear it he needs to hear I've
been trying to tell him this yeah you
don't you you you don't you no no fam we
don't do that I'm saying this by myself
no no no no no no I'm sorry you know but
the thing is
that
you you have to learn how to enjoy life
and you got to love yourself so much yes
you got to love yourself
yeah I think s so so this is the thing
right this what I've been telling a lot
of people in general I just told it to
to my guy right here Cyrus your
selfworth and how you feel about
yourself can never depend on anything
that anyone else controls you will lose
if you do it way if you wake up in the
morning and your your happiness is
determined on what a b or c feels about
you or how like you you're going to lose
in life and when you date someone that
young you're really you're really
destroying their life and let me expain
to what I
mean when a man knows he's dating a
younger woman you're really stopping her
growth in life cuz a a a real G is baby
you're too young I want you to explore
life you got to bump your head you have
to go through things like I give you
this dick yeah but and a motivational
speech right but that's all I can give
you because I'm I I care about you so
much much I don't want to take away your
experience and here's one of the things
I use I always talk about trying to date
me is like trying to get into
Harvard everybody's not going to get
accepted you have to have experience and
Life to appreciate the kind of man that
I am because if you don't have no
experiences you have no idea the gift
that you have right here but if you
bumped your head through life a few
times a few times and then you meet a
successful man right
who has benefits who can contribute to
your life you going to appreciate
because when I was young I used to I've
always been successful and I've been
through stages I've taken care of the
men's kids I bought women cars di I've
been through all at all yeah and the
thing that I remember one time I always
wanted to have somebody who was
struggling because you could save them I
could save them cuz that made me feel
good yeah well we having problems let me
take your hey y your daycare got it I
got it that made you feel good for sure
for sure I've been there when you grow
up and you really
understand it's not about you want a
woman to be physically beautiful of
course but what's your
character you want a woman to be
beautiful and what's your character but
what have you accomplished in your life
prior to meeting me because once you get
a certain age and I see now know is a
gift and a curse marriage to me unless
you know who you are is for people who
don't understand life because you go
through all the dumb [__] but when you
knowledgeable you know how your wife or
husband is supposed to be or your
girlfriend or boy supposed to be know
how to act open the door bring things
contribute to a relationship pour into
me as I pour into you as you get older
is not about the bi about this word
called sapio seexual can you talk to me
and we have
connection because as you get old that's
what makes sex better because of the way
a woman spoke to you like oh my God baby
I like what you said you know there's
some women that can just motivate a man
let's use Rocky when he was getting his
butt whooped yep and his wife was in
adri and he she said come here he's like
what she said come
here she said
when now he ran out of that damn house
started doing push-ups with one
arm for sure running up had logs on them
jumping up and down cuz his woman had
motivated him to a whole another level a
30 31 year old girl who walks around and
says that she's a woman because based on
the experiences that she has is not a
woman you you can only become a woman
with experiences and no matter what
youve gone through at 31 if you live to
be for
45 you're going to be smarter than you
was at 31 yeah if you live to be 60
something years old you going to be
smarter than you was at 45 years old
true so life is this
great experience of experiences
turmoil pitfalls hies what age did you
decide if you're Petty if you show me
that pettiness I pull the plug I think
it started in my 40s because I think in
like I said if you don't really know
knowledge you don't really have life
experience you don't know but then you
start you get a girl she argues with you
about something you have no idea what it
is so now you running out like you had a
big argument got you getting flowers you
getting all this kind of stuff because
there's something wrong with her and
most men don't take the time to figure
it out they they just deal with it they
just will deal with it here they'll just
deal with it most most men are afraid to
leave a cute girl cuz they know they
probably can't get another girl they got
lucky with this one so they they snatch
up or become jealous or overp possessor
because they feel oh I I can't get no
better than this I'm here to tell any
man about and pl and
woman you can do better things happen
and see the universe attest you and
people don't understand the universe see
God will send you somebody well let's
say the universe and that man or woman
will give you so much pain that pain is
to teach you to leave that person alone
but most people just take it but the
universe will keep giv I also feel like
what happens is you you get into a POS a
point in time where you feel you start
to feel responsible for the other person
that can happen to people as well yeah
you know especially if you if if you was
um you're the
bag if you're the bag and you bring
somebody on then all of a sudden you get
tired if you put yourself in a position
where someone's struggling and you want
to do this and it's 3 or 4 years down
the road yes now you might feel bad if
you and and as you get older you want to
have somebody that you don't have to
have a woman that put everything in the
pot no but something something and
here's why if we break up we both emot
both of us going to be emotionally
messed up for sure but financially we
should be messed up too yeah because why
said I spend hundreds of thousands and
we break up I'm feeling pain and the
financial burden but oh you said uh I
got a new car had some sex and you went
on about your
life it's just not fair